Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Thursday.
And I am just checking in on you.
Okay.
Now I know you just appointed,
you're like bill,
Bill,
you're usually yell like a maniac.
Usually act like a fucking idiot.
Well,
it's like eight 30 in the morning and I'm in a hotel room and a bar.
You're just going to have to deal with that.
All right then.
Don't act like a fucking baby about it.
I swear to God,
I'll make it up to you.
I feel like I'm talking to a child right now.
You know?
And you guys didn't even say anything.
You probably,
yeah.
You know I'm arrived at every once in a while,
Bill.
If you don't,
if he all chuck and Ami crazily,
you know,
on a Thursday or whatever.
Um,
I am in Columbus,
Ohio
and all I can tell you about Columbus,
Ohio is when you want something to eat.
When you go out of your fucking hotel room,
don't go right.
Go left at least wherever the fuck I'm staying.
I went to the right.
Can we get one of the shittiest fucking lunches I've ever had I order of it was
this little fucking Bistro to second place is calling themselves a B.
Stroh is if like,
Ooh,
this is sort of a taste of Perry here.
This is going to be like you're in Paris,
but you were in Columbus,
Ohio,
who?
Some fucking base stroke type thing,
right?
I order,
I ordered some fuck.
Oh,
well,
one of them.
Tomato,
Mozzarella,
fucking salads.
So the doe goes to me.
He goes,
hey,
you want the Balsamic vinegarette on the side?
And I said,
I'd love that because I fucking hate balsamic vinegarette on a tomato Mozzarella
fucking salad.
I don't even know why it's in there.
Okay.
It just puts some fucking olive oil on it.
A little salt
on it.
Bell pepper.
Maybe that's it.
Simple clean,
classic,
classic Italian cuisine.
Couple,
two,
three ingredients,
and it tastes like heaven,
right?
Greatest fucking cooks on earth.
What are these cons too?
They put the Balsamic vinegarette on the side.
They put the tomato in the fucking Mozzarella they put,
they put it on this iceberg lettuce,
which I can forgive you,
whatever.
God knows I need to eat a fucking salad out here.
Right?
Being on the road for two weeks.
And then for whatever fucking reason they took this creamy fucking dressing,
it just poured it all over the cheese and the tomatoes.
Why would you put fucking creamy dressing over creamy cheese?
Why would you do that?
He's supposed to add ingredients to compliment the other thing.
Not fucking reinforce it.
Like two parents yelling at you because you took the car out and wrapped it
around a tree.
Then I understand it.
These aren't two parents.
All right,
this is some tomato when some folk a Mozzarella
completely fucked that up.
And I also ordered a cup of Chili,
right?
Cause I'm an old white guy and that's what we do when we get,
we started approaching the age of 50 we start eating soup,
you know,
because that's our only hope it continues to live in,
right?
So I ordered this cup of Chili with the broth was his water.
It was just like fucking water with a little bit of hamburger helper.
My God,
the place drove me,
not nice people.
They're very nice people fucking work there.
Jesus fucking Christ,
one of these fucking places.
You walk in and there's like two registers.
So I walk up to the first one and I say to the guy and go,
hey,
can I order food from here?
And he just nods so I fucking start ordering food.
And then the fucking manager,
God comes over,
he goes,
oh,
I'm sorry.
The way it worked is you got to go to this fucking registered down here.
He didn't say fucking,
you're going to go down on that register there and order your food.
And then he'd come over here and pay and I'm looking at the fucking guy behind
the register looking like two did.
I just asked you that.
And he's just staring at me blankly like,
all right.
So I fucking go down there,
meet the person making the food fucking sweet out of a guy as it's doing,
you know,
I don't Blah Blah Blah.
I order the shit now.
I go to walk back down to fucking pay at the register and some conscious walks
off the street.
It walks up to that register in order as a cup of coffee,
right?
And then servicing the guy.
So now I'm behind him.
It's that kind of fucked as this work.
Oh,
and this one,
you just pay cash or you order coffee.
So now this fucking guy who wasn't in front of me is now some out in front of
me.
I don't understand it.
I don't fucking understand it.
And then I sit down and go to eat the shit.
It was one of those deals where I had to take the knife and I'm scraping the
fucking awful shit off of the shit that you want to eat.
And I'm not going to lie to you.
It put me in a mood.
I'll put me in a mood.
I was going to be like,
you know what?
Fuck Columbus.
Fuck this whole fucking state.
And he fucking state that puts creamy dressing on Nice fucking hunk.
So mood sedan.
I'm fucking Outta here.
I don't need to have a come back.
Right.
But the evening was saved by an unbelievable crowd,
a beautiful fucking theater.
And,
uh,
we ended up going to this bar late night,
the elevator and a great bartender,
Pittsburgh guy.
And it means a couple of fucking drinks.
We just laughing our balls off,
telling whole coke and stories.
And then we ended the night up watching the beginning of good fellas on the bus
and then they called it a fucking night.
I don't be in a whiny cunt,
but why,
why would you do that?
Perfectly good fucking food.
You know what I mean?
Well,
why would you do that?
Um,
the fuck was I just going to talk about in there.
I spaced on something.
Tomato the moots or Ale fucking Dan.
Yeah,
let me know
and I'll follow.
You know what,
somebody from after the,
uh,
after the show came up to me and,
he,
he gave me,
I want to thank the person who once again he got me this drum DVD that Joe,
Joe Mayor,
you know,
top secret stuff for the,
uh,
the modern drummer,
basically all that molar method stuff.
Uh,
it's really fucking nice to you.
And when I was in Cincinnati,
uh,
somebody interviewed me,
a comedian,
Muhammad came,
I got me some Pete rose tee shirts.
I got you backstage passes young buck comedian.
I didn't,
you never came back.
I hope you made it out to the show.
I double checked that they had your name at the door.
I hope you fucking made it.
Now I'm all fucking paranoid.
They didn't let you in and you hook me up with some tee shirts and you like that
fucking bill burrs to biggest Fred had had contact ever met in my life.
Um,
so anyways,
here we've been having a great time.
We had a great time to Cincinnati.
I'm trying to think where the fuck we been since I last talked to you guys.
See it was Fort Wayne,
Cincinnati.
Then we did Dayton dirty Dayton.
They called their fucking town that 30 day or something like that.
I was going,
why the fuck would you call yourself to,
and this is why you don't get any tourism here.
You know,
I don't fucking know.
Whatever.
I've been having a great time and I'm
at keeps getting fucking,
I think,
oh actually been doing too much time,
but doing like an hour and a half for the last couple of nights.
I got to tighten it up a little bit.
But um,
what do I get tonight?
I got Pittsburgh and then I got Cleveland and that's,
that's the first leg than the first leg is fucking done.
Just like that.
The first week is over.
But last night when I was on stage,
my beloved Boston Bruins,
my fucking hat dude,
they paid the filthy flyers in the fucking new Boston Garden,
the Td Bank,
fucking JP Morgan Center,
whatever the fuck they call it.
You know,
those 40,000 cinder blocks that they went out and bought and built a big square
building.
Nothing interesting.
Architecturally speaking,
there are only one of the original six teams.
Why would you give them a fucking,
you know,
the Columbus blue jackets should have a better facility.
The Minnesota wild should have a better looking fucking ranked than the Boston
Bruins.
That completely makes sense.
Right.
You know,
Geez.
Um,
I'm going to rewind.
Well,
after this tour,
I'm Mexican and watch the game.
I did watch the highlights and um,
as much as a fucking brutal heartbreaker that was that they,
they lost in overtime.
We did get a point and a,
as far as I was watching with the highlights,
we look,
uh,
you know,
we look like a fucking decent team and I was really nervous about that,
so I'm happy with it.
These guys are still fucking Gel and that came,
I can tell you right now as a game,
we would have lost a week ago.
You know what I mean?
You know,
maybe a week and a half ago and guys,
we're still getting to know each other or whatever.
The fact that we just blew it and overtime I feel as a step forward,
right?
Ooh.
Um,
I was actually on the bus and I saying,
well,
what's the score?
Cause it fucking satellite thing wasn't working and adverse.
He looked it up set.
It was a,
you know,
four to two and I was so fucking excited,
but I also knew there was like 13 minutes left and I was like,
oh Jesus,
42 we'd been up three games to none against these guys and couldn't fucking
close it up.
God Damn filthy flyers.
Gay Men,
congratulations to them.
You know,
they were supposed to suck this year,
won't they?
Bruins and out.
Well maybe we just to shitty teams passing in the night.
I have no idea.
I don't think was shitty though.
Speaking and not shitty.
I bought those fucking Canadians
seven and Oh,
do you know what actually bothers me as a Bruins fan?
Knowing how happy Canadian fans,
I don't hate the Canadians.
I've realized that over the years,
it was never about the Canadians.
It was about this silly sock where in French,
French frenchies up there and join yet another Stanley Cup victory.
And I got to tell you,
I've completely enjoyed the,
the,
the 20 something year drought of your Stanley Cups.
And uh,
even I as a,
as a,
as a fucking Canadian hater got to say,
this is easily the most scared.
I've been in fucking over 20 years and you guys were going to fucking end the
drought.
Um,
God knows we're not going to be the ones to stop you.
So I'm rooting for the fucking West to be a monster of a fuck.
It's somebody out there to be another black hawks.
Got To do it again.
Who knows?
Uh,
speaking of which,
my condolences to the a Chicago cub fan and congratulations to the mats and,
uh,
you know,
I had half an eye on that fucking series.
I've been traveling around in Jesus Christ.
Um,
I don't think there's ever been an easier MVP trophy to,
uh,
to be given out than to give it to fucking Daniel Murphy,
Jesus Christ.
I didn't even realize,
I knew he had some fucking home runs.
I didn't realize he hits six games in a fucking row.
That's ridiculous.
That's from a second baseman man.
Unfucking believable.
So,
uh,
I really wish I had time to watch that series.
I had no fucking idea.
Um,
and I'm glad I didn't see the Clo.
I guess it wasn't a,
the new Shea stadium,
you know,
cause I'll tell you,
them panning around the crowd when,
uh,
the cubs were going down three games to none or whatever the fuck it was.
That reminded me a long time ago,
you know,
when the red sox were going through their shit.
So,
uh,
that sucks for them,
but they're a young team.
They could get better next year.
Poo who?
Um,
but you know,
really quickly,
by the way,
you know what really fucking annoyed me was the amount of cubs fans that fucking
filed out of that stadium.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Half the fucking stadium left.
And I've always maintained that,
that for every fucking team,
half the people there are actually true fans.
The rest of them just show up.
You know,
like all those fucking country met fans that have caught met fever,
you know,
where were you a couple of years ago when they sucked for fucking 10 years?
Where were,
you know what you were at home with the girlfriend sitting there watching
fucking survivor or something like that.
Like,
dude,
I'm,
I'm not watching the mets.
Uh,
can't a kid of the biggest myths fan or can't fuck you.
Where the fuck were you?
Right.
I can say that about the important teams to all these fucking Patriot fans where
to fuck with you.
And we used to play in that high school football stadium,
but those a little bit of benches and you stood up and you've fucking lost his
seat.
Where were you?
You were at home.
I've been so fucking
chowder.
Um,
so anyways,
you know,
my dumb ass is going to do,
like I couldn't be watching any more fucking sports is my life is whizzing by.
I think I'm going to get the NBA package this year.
I don't know why.
I just think the Celtics are going to be fun to watch this year and I,
you know,
I'd never been a big basketball fit.
You know,
I just,
I,
I can't get into it.
It's like they score every fucking three seconds.
Anytime anybody looks at anybody.
It's a fucking filed.
I,
you know,
it's kind of like soccer except you can use your hands,
except there's also a ton of scoring.
It's not that obviously it's not that bad.
Um,
I don't know.
I think I liked college hoops better,
but whatever.
Hey,
by the way,
um,
as far as my workout regimen by go to the gym every day,
you know what?
I also have been eating like a fucking,
okay.
Uh,
I been eating like a fat girl on Prom night.
How come nobody took me?
Um,
what did I have to go up to fat girls?
Maybe I could say I was eating like a redhead,
a redheaded mail on prom night.
I don't know.
Um,
oh my God,
I've been eating like a fucking animal.
I've also been working out like an animal,
so I've gone up one notch and the old belt there,
but uh,
that's kind of been my game plan because every night I say I'm not going to
drink and I'm not going to act like a fucking idiot.
But,
uh,
I'm hanging out with my three best friends in the fucking world on this tour.
You know,
what are we going to do?
And it's always every night,
right before the show,
we always say the same thing too.
When are going to go easy tonight,
you know,
we're going to go easy and uh,
fucking you don't,
we've got Pittsburgh tomorrow night.
It's Columbus,
you know,
it's going to be quiet town after the show.
Let's,
she's,
let's just fucking go home.
All right?
And everybody goes,
yeah,
yeah.
Good idea.
Right?
Then what happens?
You know,
somebody just gives one,
somebody look,
you know
somebody last night it was [inaudible] first he gave me look,
just going like,
uh,
so what do you think?
You know,
he was done with the set.
I hadn't gone on yet.
You know?
What do you think it's maybe a going back to the hotel,
just calling it a night and then I just start laughing and he starts laughing
and the next thing you know,
we stay out till fucking three in the morning,
like assholes.
Fucking assholes.
Who likes,
who likes working out?
Honestly,
I'm sure you like it in your twenties but at my age it's not a fun thing to do.
And I go on,
I work out,
I do all his fucking sweating and fucking my old God damn knees and all this
shit.
And then what do I do?
I give it away,
you know?
Come back here.
We need a sleeve of fucking Oreo cookies.
I'm thinking of the back of my head like,
what am I doing?
Literally two of these fucking cookies.
That's probably 40 minutes.
How many calories are in a fucking Oreo cookie?
Oh my God,
dude,
yesterday when I bought the Oreo cookies,
right?
Am I already hated myself already fat shaming myself.
It's like the middle of the day two.
I bought him a broad day light,
wherever I felt like everybody was looking at me.
Go look it up,
look at him eating his cookies,
right?
And I go walking by and there was this Asian Dude,
I don't know where he was from,
but uh,
he was definitely an immigrant because he had the hardcore fucking accident,
right?
Just one of these fucking guys made you smile.
You had great fucking energy.
And he just went like,
oh,
hello.
How are,
you know,
he's fucking cleaning up vacuum in Assam Shit,
right?
Classic immigrant job.
And I say,
how you doing man?
How's it going?
He goes up,
do I go do?
Then he just goes and sees the cookies.
He just goes,
I hope I'm going to be able to do it.
I smoked a cigar last night.
He looks at the cookers and you just goes,
Oreo.
And I just started fucking last.
And I go,
yeah man,
I got some Oreos and it goes,
all those are my favorites and I'm laughing going,
I love him too.
But it sounded like he was shitting on me the way he went or real.
It's like,
you fucking bitch,
you bringing cookies back there.
There's sugar,
tits,
dude,
it made my fucking afternoon.
He was such a fucking funny guy and he wasn't being a bad guy.
That's what I loved about him.
He was actually,
he was more saying it like a big black or like,
hey,
right,
like that's what I'm talking about.
What I love was,
it was just me and him in the lobby and they had a big ceiling and it was like
echoed when he did it.
Oreo.
I went upstairs and I sit down like a fucking loser and I start eating with a
sleeve of cookies with his voice ringing in my head and I was laughing,
eating the cookies and I swear to God for one second I almost started crying.
There's no way.
If you're any sort of a human being to sit in a hotel room by yourself and need
a sleeve of Oreo and not just feel a wave of depression wash over you.
It's one of the saddest things you can ever do.
If you've noticed,
I can't even know.
I don't even know if they even have,
do they even have commercials for Oreos?
Do they even need to?
You know what I mean?
It's like the Jordan of fucking cookies.
As far as none other than the ones your mom makes or something,
you know,
some lonely cut like me makes a homemade are going to be better,
but it's just as far as like store bought cookies.
Okay,
let's start a battle here.
Right?
Let's start a debate.
C'Mon.
Are you guys aren't a sea going to sit there and tell him he can fuck with Oreo
cookies?
It is.
It's the perfect fucking cookie.
And you know what kills me is when you bite off one side and then you bite off
another side,
another one,
you stick them together to make your own double stuff on.
Why does that one taste so much better than the actual double stuff?
One that's doing the work for you.
You know what I mean?
When you buy the double stuff once it's just like it,
there's too much of the cream in it,
you know,
and it just too sugary and you can't fucking eat them.
But when you do the other ones,
I don't know who the fuck is in charge of that over there at Oreo.
Just dial back the frosting.
You went a little too fucking hard and it's not ringing God damn true.
Um,
without a doubt that my,
my favorite fucking cookie and uh,
was it territo says you can't just have one fucked to raise by the way,
everybody,
you know what?
You know what Doritos are?
I'm 47 years old.
Anybody under the age of light 40 Doritos or this shit original Doritos,
you cannot fuck with them.
They're considered the greatest chip of all time.
I grew up on,
I grew up on Fritos.
Ruffles like Pringles are still new to me.
Like when those things first came out and they stacked them up and that can
like,
we would just like to what that,
what that was like when,
for my generation,
that was like when playstation first came out,
tap potato chips that you could actually stack up,
you know,
to have like fucking 300 potato chips that are actually on the same page.
You know what I mean?
As opposed to the usual one.
You open up a bag,
they're all going a different direction.
You know,
like some fucking team with a coach lost the locker room,
right?
Pringles,
a the fucking New England patriots.
They got a system and everybody does their fucking job and they get it done
right.
And they're so God damn good about it.
The crying coats,
coats got to fucking talk about air pressure.
By the way,
I watched this fucking thing.
Uh,
yesterday,
one of those 30 for thirties,
on a old pistol,
Pete Carroll at the,
uh,
when he coached for USC.
Dude,
I can't fucking believe I missed,
I missed that whole era.
I don't think I watched one fucking game.
I was so busy traveling to all of these,
I'm going to right now,
which by the way is bring it back a ton of memories.
Um,
I remember I went to an Ohio state game against like,
I can't remember who the fuck they play the game with a B
wasn't,
believe me,
it wasn't Boise state.
It was just some fucking shit.
Head team,
division three way back in the day,
those classic cupcake games.
I went to it by myself.
I fucking came here and I went into their old basketball arena where the band
plays before the game.
And I went into the horseshoe,
which isn't a horse shoe anymore.
Nobody really has a horse shoe unless you're fucking programs.
Thanks again.
They got to build,
you know,
they've got to keep adding onto the stadium because people keep fucking right
and there's too many God damn people and there's traffic.
24,
seven,
we got to have enough extra seats to put these animals right.
And I went to the game by myself.
Um,
I have a lot of memories of that.
I'm going to go to Milwaukee.
I,
I've been to county stadium and the Miller Park.
I've been to both of those by myself.
I still remember at Miller Park would,
somebody took my picture.
I had him take my picture on one of those little fucking disposable cameras and
they did the thing where they took it from my neck up.
And like the top of the picture is like the entire fucking stadium and the,
and the roof of it.
Just one of the worst pictures of all time.
Actually just laughed.
I got a stack of those somewhere,
like little,
those little fucking five by eight printouts that you get when you took it to
the,
uh,
the drug store to get them developed of me standing in front of about 40
different stadiums that no longer exist.
Um,
let me see if I can go through some of them.
Let's see.
Okay.
I've been to Olympia stadium,
one of the fuck that was for an expos game.
That still exists,
but the expos don't Miller park the kingdom.
Okay.
Uh,
the Astro Dome Mile High Stadium,
Sullivan Stadium,
the Boston Garden.
Jesus Christ.
I even took a tour of fucking maple leaf garden by myself,
one on this fucking tour.
It's one of the cool tours I took.
I aim to fucking older my be all these fucking place candlestick
the fuck else did I go Mick Nichols arena.
It's where the nuggets played.
I went there by myself doing a college gig
watching the fucking Denver Nuggets and they were terrible.
That was one of those deals.
And they were barely in the fucking leave.
I saw an avalanche game there too,
before they built the Pepsi Center.
Um,
the Old Dallas Cowboys Stadium.
I,
you know,
one of these days I,
I gotta make a list of all the fucking stadiums I've been to that no longer
fucking exist.
And not only did I go there,
I went there by myself.
But anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
So,
um,
yeah,
I do too.
I just been working out and eating like a fucking moron.
And tonight I'm going to Pittsburgh and I got a ton of friends there.
Randy bombing,
um,
Bill Crawford from Wd v,
you know,
Randy always say he built me up in that market.
He's the reason why I sell tickets there.
So we always hang up and then we always end up at that fucking the,
the,
the evil yet delicious.
Whatever the,
I always forget the name of it,
the fucking sandwich where they put the French fries on it.
All these fucking Pittsburgh guys are screaming about it,
uh,
to Nerys pin.
Amies Peramis I always forget the name of it,
the fucking sandwich there where they put all this shit on it because,
you know,
I forget why it had to do with fucking people building bridges and they just
needed to stick everything that they were going to eat for lunch in between
bread and they shoved it down their fucking throats and then they just ate it.
Um,
we're gonna end up there and of course we're going to have some fucking drinks
and then we're going to end up in a Cleveland the next night and when we go to
fucking Cleveland,
um,
by the way,
the after party,
I never have after parties.
So,
you know,
this is going to be a special night.
Uh,
the after party is going to be at hilarity.
His comedy club downstairs at the a Martini bar.
So,
uh,
if you want to come down there,
me,
Bart,
nick,
and lie at are all going to be there.
Um,
stop by,
come up,
say hello.
You know,
just by a couple of drinks in there because nick costs,
this is another guy that fucking,
you know,
that guy used to headline me when I would fill up like a third of his club and
he built me up in that market.
So,
you know,
coming through town and,
uh,
I,
we stopped in and make sure I pay my respects to one of the legends in standup
comedy.
So,
uh,
please come down there,
you know,
stop by,
say hello to us and uh,
by a couple of drinks and uh,
yeah,
whatever.
So,
but I think after that,
then we're in Indianapolis.
That's another fun time to drink.
And you know,
at some point I just have to admit that I like to drink,
right.
But I'm just going to keep working on,
I'm trying to fucking,
I'm losing the battle,
you know what I mean?
Like I've put on like,
you know,
a couple,
two,
three here,
but you know,
I'm still going to the gym.
So rather than putting on a fucking seven,
putting out two,
three pounds is a bad,
you put on seven,
that's when you just start to give up on yourself.
Don't give up on me,
be um,
that's when he started giving up on yourself and then you fucking in trouble.
Um,
all right.
Can I talk good fellas here?
The Greatest Guy fucking movie of all time.
We watched it again and it's just,
I was watching it last night and what I realized is it's just a bunch of scenes
that to me is far as like a standup comic goes.
It's the equivalent of an unbelievable closing joke,
like a chunk of material.
But it's every fucking scene.
Every scene is a fucking closer.
It's the greatest fucking movie that's ever been made.
I,
it just does.
You cannot,
that's up perfect fucking movie.
And every time I watch it,
I see something different.
You know,
it was fucking great.
It wasn't the beginning of the movie when it's raining out right.
At a young Henry Hill is holding the umbrella.
And that guy who gets mad at them for wasting a prince,
he's got the cigar in his mouth,
the run that he does,
the way he runs over to Polly's house and then he runs back over the phone,
his run and the unlit cigar in his mouth is just so fucking perfect,
get kills me.
So fucking masterpiece.
So we watched it so many times.
I'm trying to,
uh,
you know,
I've got a couple of questions cause everything in there means something,
Scorsese,
you know what means something.
So I want to ask you guys a question.
I came up with a theory.
Do you know when they,
uh,
when they got Billy batts in the trunk of the car,
right?
And they open it up and he's still alive and they fucking shoot them and stab
him and all of that.
You know,
it's backlit and it's all red.
And then again,
when they go to dig them up,
it's all fucking red like this.
The whole sky isn't just the brake lights of the car.
It's the whole fucking sky.
And my theory was,
the reason why it was red was because that move who's quite got Tommy whacked.
Okay.
And that was sort of the beginning of the end of their crew.
You know what I mean?
That's like a theory.
I have the theory I have about,
okay,
in the end when Henry Hill is fucking crying like a fucking bitch and the end,
by the end of the movie,
I hate the character because he fucking need went out dead.
Exactly what fucking Paulie told them not to do.
And then he gets caught.
He fucking rats everybody else.
And he's fucking Billy.
I get egg noodles and ketchup.
If they do,
dude,
you should be in fucking jail.
You can't,
um,
the add,
you know,
when he's sitting there talking,
when he just got done testifying,
all of a sudden they cut to Tommy and he just brings the gun up and he just
starts shooting.
That's Tommy from beyond the grave
because he ratted out Jimmy and,
and,
and uh,
and Paulie.
I think that that's him coming back from the grades.
Like,
this is what I would have fucking done.
Do you Henry?
I would've fucking whacked it.
These are all just my theories.
Joe To Rosa has a great theory where at some point Pauley is,
is talking to Henry Hill and he's making those sausages.
He said there's a,
there's a,
there's an expression the pigs are in the fire,
which means shit has already been set in motion as he's sitting telling them not
to fucking get involved with drugs.
Like that's the level.
Like I'm trying to watch the movie at this point.
So I've got a question for you to just basically when it's backlit and red,
why do you think it's backlit red like that?
And then also why did they cut to that fucking old school clip or that guy
singing?
Um,
you know,
he's whistle on like a bird.
You know that part goodbye.
[inaudible] goodbye.
You know when they show that part of saint a virtualized,
they go,
why do you think he shows that clip you in?
It's like,
you know,
it means something.
I'm trying to think of the era.
I'm trying to think of the lyrics of the song for the life of me.
I don't have a fucking theory.
You guys put,
does this sound like Consumer Mike?
My conspiracy theory sticks,
but accept them.
Uh,
I'm fucking talking about good fellas.
I Dunno.
Anyways.
Um,
oh,
last time was for God last night when I was at the,
uh,
at the theater here in Columbus.
Um,
they had all like these Broadway shows,
you know,
where they,
they,
they would put like the logo and he or they put like a cats or whatever the
fuck.
I can't,
I don't know what the fuck they are,
you know,
Mama Mia,
all that stuff.
And the,
uh,
then the whole cast would sign.
I always look at all those things and I always think it's fucking cool.
I'm looking at all that stuff and all the performers and the bands and all of
that shit.
And uh,
so I saw the monkeys were up on the wall and I was a big monkeys fan.
I love the TV show.
When I was a kid.
I thought it was funny as hell and I liked the fucking songs.
And uh,
I'm looking up there and I see Davy Jones,
his signature from the 2001 tour.
David Jones,
rest his soul.
Peter Torque,
Micky Dolenz that I'm looking going,
did Mike Nesmith ever come back?
He never came back to dirty.
And then right as I was thinking like,
oh wait a minute,
way back in the day,
like I'm going back like 12,
13 years ago,
I used to take drum lessons at this place called the a drummer's collective,
the drama collective in New York City,
which just has a bunch of monster fucking players down there.
These just unbelievably gifted kids go there and then they have these sick ass
fucking teachers there and um,
you know,
but then like a jerk off like me can just come in and start taking lessons.
They don't care.
Like whatever your talent level is,
you know,
they'll teach her right and outright.
As I was looking at the monkeys thing,
I was like,
wait a minute.
I used to take lessons from this guy,
sandy genero big time Yankee fan lived in Staten Island and I was,
you know,
obviously a red sox fan and that was when the curse was still going on.
And I remember I was taking lessons during 2003 and I remember when Pedro
fucking through grab Don Zimmer by Jacqueline,
Jacqueline and head in fucking threw him down on the ground.
And uh,
I used to do a bit about that,
defending,
uh,
Pedro Martinez going he out and he what,
what were his options to turn around and run.
Then he's running around from an old man,
you know,
to hold his ground and punch him.
He can't do that cause he's an old man or three,
grab him by his big Macy day head.
And so to guide them down to the ground and it actually would get a laugh in New
York.
But last night,
Joe Part,
Nick finally convinced me it was the wrong thing to do cause he looked at me and
he just goes,
pill.
He goes,
it was don Zimmer,
he's an old man because it old man comes from at you.
You just put your arms out and you hug them.
You know,
he just got done you baseball.
I can't do this to you and I just put my head down at this point.
You're right.
Okay.
And then for,
as he told the story that I guess,
I don't know,
at some point,
I think after retired or whatever,
there's a,
there's a baseball story out there that Pedro sat down and had lunch with,
uh,
um,
which George Steinbrenner,
the late great George Steinbrenner.
Right.
And to break the ice because that was still hanging in the air.
He sits down with them and he just sort of looks,
Pedro looks down,
he just goes,
bless me father for I have sinned.
And I guess Steinberg and just started laughing and then it was fucking over a
fucking cool.
Is that,
um,
I don't even care if it didn't happen.
I just think it's a great fucking story.
So,
uh,
anyways,
so I used to take drum lessons from,
uh,
sandy genero and like he was a monster fucking player to get an unbelievable
based on foot.
And he was the first guy that showed me that slide step thing because I was
going through probably my 50th obsession with John Bonham and he was the guy who
finally showed me how to do that.
Um,
and he was doing the good times,
bad times,
licking and all that stuff.
He was just a monster player.
And one of the things he did,
um,
he used to get,
uh,
Peter Criss from kiss ready to go out on tour,
you know,
if we just take them through the paces and all that,
get them up to speed so we could go out and go kill it with the,
with the van kiss and a,
and another thing he did was he played,
um,
he played drums with the monkeys when they would go on the road.
And,
and I,
I hadn't thought about taking lessons with them in such a long fucking time.
So I'm sitting there in Columbus and,
um,
I'm looking at the monkeys thing and I see Peter Torque,
Davy Jones and Micky Dolenz.
And I was thinking and it right as I thought,
wait a minute,
ice,
take drum lessons from a guy,
sandy generra.
We used to play with these guys and he,
and I know he was on tour with these guys during the time.
And right.
Then I looked and I saw his fucking signature was coolest shit.
I took a picture of it and um,
he also played with Cindy Lopper like he did like that's the cool thing about
drama collective.
Like they,
they'd fucking major,
major drummers.
There was another guy down and he could just walk in like a fucking bum like me
and you could just take fucking lessons from,
they had another guy down there.
MMM.
The fuck is his name.
I'm going blank on it.
He used to play with a
Herbie Hancock.
Let me look this up.
Rory handcuffed.
The guy played on the loft funk.
I mean,
uh,
you can't,
here we go.
Come on and build.
Learn how to spell
funk,
drummer
something simple.
Mike something or other.
My Clark,
I could believe it.
When I went down there,
I just saw the guy go walking by and I was like,
is that fucking my clock to go?
Yeah.
I go,
what is he doing it again?
I,
he's wanting to teachers so you can take a fucking less than what that guy said
it.
Listen to his shit.
Trying to figure out how to fucking do it.
He could actually walk down and take a lesson.
And I know there's some of you younger guys,
this is no big fucking deal cause you got youtube and he can just watch the guy
and break it down and slow it down.
And I have some guy,
but back in the day you couldn't do that.
And I was just like,
this is why it's great to live in fucking New York City.
These fucking guys are actually out here.
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
I'll end on this thing here and I'm gonna have to punch in the,
the advertising because I haven't gotten it yet.
I'll have to put it in later on when I'm on the bus.
Um,
but anyways,
uh,
I,
I discovered a fucking drummer.
I don't know how,
where I was a guy,
Chris Coleman,
and he dramas out,
they're familiar with this guys when these Gospel Drummers guys fucking
unbelievable.
I just stumbled upon a,
uh,
the,
I watch a bunch of drum videos on youtube.
They always have them on the fucking sides.
And,
uh,
it just popped up and I was like,
who is this cow?
Check out.
This guy's playing just a fucking unbelievable solar.
So,
uh,
I'm gonna put the,
I'll post a clip of the picture.
I took a theater here in Columbus,
uh,
with the monkeys and that Sandy Janeiro's signature drew a little drum man.
It was fucking cool as shit.
And uh,
and also,
uh,
the video clip of Chris Coleman.
Um,
by the way,
before I get Outta here,
a must win fucking gang.
Obviously for Kansas City,
Kansas City has to win this,
this game,
six or,
uh,
I don't know,
man.
I think Toronto might come back and if they go back to their home,
you know,
uh,
it's turned into a great series.
Remember I was bitching about that when they were down fucking,
uh,
oh to telling them,
you know,
I want to see a seven game fucking series and look at that.
Hey,
they come,
they come storming back.
He got to give it up to Toronto.
Even if they don't fucking win this next woman that teams got major fucking
heart.
Uh,
I can't believe I'm missing all these fucking games.
I mean,
I obviously I'm already having a great fucking time,
but,
uh,
this is the time of year.
I like to be home to actually fucking watch a bunch of baseball.
So,
uh,
um,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
Whatever.
I gotta go,
fuck.
Got To get running here.
How can you know what I gotta do?
I gotta go fucking work off at least maybe three of these goddamn cookies.
Do you want me fucking cookies that were in here?
Let me see.
How many servings say,
say this is,
you know,
cause they was,
let's see here.
Amount of servings,
calories,
160 calories from fat.
60 serving is three cookies.
Yeah,
serving per kid per container is about 4.5.
So I had enough Oreo cookies for four and a half.
Fucking people's being fucking freckled content
hundred 60 cow amount per serving
is one 60.
There's no way for that.
There's no way.
Three cookies are 160.
That's gotta be 160 per cookie.
All right,
Bill,
do the math.
That's 300 plus one 80.
That's 480 calories.
Times three.
There's over 12 cookies.
Oh,
you fucking jerk off.
So I got to multiply that three 80 times four.
Okay.
That's 1,203.
2015.
Over 1500 fucking calories.
You have a fucking just sweat your balls off on the elliptical for an hour.
You're lucky if you make 600 fucking calories.
Oh Dude,
I gotta I gotta go to the front.
I got to go downstairs.
I get to hit the gym before I get on the bus.
All right,
that's the,
uh,
Thursday afternoon podcast.
I know it was kind of all over the place.
I'm going to try to get some of the guys on the podcast from Monday.
Uh,
that is it.
Thank you to everybody that's been coming out to the shows.
And um,
once again,
thank you again for the people who brought up the drum videos and the tee shirts
and all that shit.
You guys don't have to do that stuff.
All right?
You don't have to do that.
Um,
I got a ton of fucking shit already did I got to get rid of and uh,
you know,
the last thing I need is more cool.
I'm never going to be able to throw out those Pete rose tee shirts.
That too fucking cool.
Right?
And then I buy whatever I gotta throw it.
I got it.
No,
I have not.
I have to throw something out.
Well,
my old Quebec Nordiques t shirt,
I'm not fucking throwing that out.
It's starting to spill it to my wife's side of the closet.
I'm like a broad was shoes except it's t shirts over there.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Like I said for this Thursday,
you guys have a great weekend and enjoy the,
uh,
the throwback half hour,
the second half here,
that Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcasts just before Friday where I just check it on you.
Alright,
now it's time for the rates and no,
I haven't gone to the gym yet and yes,
it is a few hours into the future and I am on my iPhone over there.
All right.
Blue Apron Epi buddy.
It's okay.
You can admit it.
The last thing anyone wants to after work is wait in line at the grocery store,
Schlep home and cook a complicated Goddamn meal and expensive,
unhealthy takeout is hardly better.
Hey,
I should know I'm living it right now.
That's where the new service blue apron comes in.
Did I mention I went to white castle a few nights ago?
Oh,
I'm telling that.
Or ruffling blue apron delivers farm fresh ingredients and step by step recipes
to your home,
allowing you to create healthy,
handcrafted meals at home without going to the grocery store for less than $10
per meal.
Blue Apron sends you fresh ingredients,
perfectly proportioned,
making,
cooking healthy meals,
really easy and fun.
No trips to the grocery store,
no waste from unused ingredients.
Plus you learn how to cook with specially specialty specialty ingredients.
Jesus Christ that are normally hard to find.
Blue Apron is perfect for date night cooking with friends and they even offer
family plans with kid friendly ingredients so the whole family can eat well and
have fun preparing meals together.
Oh boy.
Let's make it feel much.
Each balanced meal is 500 to 700 calories per serving and so tasty that you'd
never know it.
Cooking takes half an hour.
Shipping is flexible and free and the menus are always knew they won't send the
same meal twice.
I love that.
It's so tasty.
You'd never know cause you know a bunch of fat fucks who like fiber and it's 700
calories doesn't taste good unless it's three Oreos.
Maybe that was me thinking that.
Anyways,
they work around your schedule and dietary preferences and blue apron experts
source only the best seasonal ingredients for incredible meals like Parmesan
crusted chicken with roasted heirloom potatoes.
Jesus Christ,
that sounds delicious and tomato,
a rubella salad and Tandoori spice chicken with green lentils,
eggplant and Cucumber Mint Yogurt.
You'll cook incredible meals and be blown away by the quality and freshness.
Blue Apron.
It's a better way to cook.
Check out this week's menu and get your first two meals for free by going to
blue apron.com/burr.
My treat,
really the first two meals are on me.
Well it's really on them,
but that'd be nice about it.
Saying that it's on me when you go to blue apron.com/burr.
All right.
Oh Jesus,
I got to sing with my cigar voice here,
but it boop,
boop me undies me on these.
No more sweaty Tate [inaudible] me undies.
Your balls or drive,
don't say they ain't.
When you got that Nice fucking materially up against your nuts,
you'll fucking life will never get in the ruts.
Oh,
gets me undies.
They got,
and for the ladies,
they keep their clams dry too.
Unless you fuck them.
They're really a nice pair of undies.
Oh yeah.
Why don't you go get some?
Yeah,
me undies.
We all know how sexy confidence can be and that confidence comes from being
comfortable.
But how can you feel great if your underwear's wrinkling and riding up beyond
these gets it.
And that's why they've created the world's most comfortable underwear for a
daily dose of confidence.
When you look good,
you feel great.
It's a cliche.
You know why?
Because it's true.
Mandy's understands this and that's why they designed underwear that makes you
look and feel fantastic.
Please include the file.
I'm going to do it.
Me undies is made from Madell model modal,
a fabric that's twice as soft.
Just cough,
cough.
That's twice the softest.
Whatever underwear you're wearing right now,
he says tons of colors and styles and they only place you only place to get
matching pairs for men and women.
That's kind of weird.
Talk about stuck in a fucking relationship.
Your underwear's get a match or panties.
No,
Jesus.
They even released a new design every month.
Um,
I wear whatever free ones they give me and they feel great.
My balls have never been happier.
Plus we all,
we all know that paying for shipping sucks,
man.
So me,
Andy says,
removed that from the equation.
All orders in the U S and Canada shipped for free.
Me undies even has a money back guarantee.
If you don't love that your first pair,
you can get it.
You can keep it for free.
You literally have nothing to lose.
To sweeten the deal.
Me Is offering you 20% off your first order at [inaudible] dot com slash burr.
I thought they were going to sprinkle a little salt in the crotch area.
You know,
the sweetened the deal.
So a little sugar,
uh,
go against you bolt.
This is a special offer for just my listeners.
Make sure you go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr to get 20% off your first
order so that they know that we sent you.
All right?
That's it.
I'll go listen to the old school stuff if you want to.
If not,
I appreciate you listening in
here.
Oh,
by the way,
I want to thank the 43,000 people who sent me that story about how the world's
largest sperm bank has been turning away the ges of redheads.
Okay?
Uh,
bank,
uh,
biggest sperm,
world's biggest sperm bank tells red heads we don't need your semen.
No fucking degrading.
That is you showing up to jerk off into a Dixie Cup and they turn you away.
Like,
Nah,
that's all right.
That's,
that's like telling a stripper to put clothes back on.
He's fucking horrific,
you know?
But for some reason,
like people think that that affects my life.
It doesn't,
all right,
they turn away a lot of fucking people.
Okay.
If you got different shit and your family,
they turn you away.
And not to mention,
I got to tell you as a guy,
that story has no effect on you.
Okay?
As far as your ges,
I guess.
Yeah.
I can't sell my ges to a sperm bank.
I mean,
how,
what sort of financial fucking crisis am I going to be and where I'm going down
to a Duane Reades in the lube and then limping into a sperm bank to fucking
shoot something into a goddamn graduated cylinder.
You know,
rarely.
I can't fucking do that.
You think I give a fuck?
Let me tell you something.
This is what I've learned is what I learned in life.
Okay?
If you're making money,
they'll
want you fucking ges.
I don't give a fuck what you look like.
You can be a one eyed balled midget troll they wanted in them.
All right?
Trust me.
So any redhead who took that in a bad fucking way,
just go out and make something yourself.
I'm telling you,
you'll get a fucking 10 and you'll dump a fucking nice unwanted spoons right in
her.
That was disgusting.
Yet pro redhead.
How do you like that?
Everybody pro fucking redhead.
Um,
I just loved,
I just love how many people sent me that story.
Like I swear to God,
I said 40,000,
but it had to be at least be a hundred.
And that's one of the things that I love about the Internet and I hate it at the
same time because the Internet,
I swear to God,
allows adults to act the same way you acted when you were in like kindergarten
or first grade on the playground where you would just completely uninhibited and
you were mean.
Remember that Shit.
You just walk up to somebody and be like,
I don't like your face.
Right?
You could just be that.
And then when you get older,
you still think that he saw you sitting there in the board room going into this
guy with his fucking face,
his stupid fucking tie,
right?
You think childish shit,
but because you're older and mature,
you don't say it.
You know,
because you know you've got debt.
You don't want to get fired.
Well,
he's doing a great job.
And they told the boss,
uh,
he didn't like his face.
That'd be Hilarie.
Why did you get fired from your last job?
You know?
And he had to tell him some childish shit like that.
Well,
the great thing is about the Internet is it allows you to tap back into that
part of you,
you know,
and,
and actually,
and then debunk the fucking myth that when you become an adult,
you still don't think those thoughts that you did when you were in first grade
because you're now you're older and mature.
You still think I'm you just programmed not to fucking say him.
So,
uh,
I don't know it.
At first I was like,
what the fuck?
And then by the time I,
the 11th person sent it to me and,
and actually this,
this story broke like,
like two weeks ago.
And like two weeks in is people are still sending me this story.
That's what maybe find the Internet fucking hilarious.
The fact that somebody's going to listen to this podcast and then send it to me
on Twitter after it.
That's like that.
That's literally that I don't wake your face Nana Nan ass shit.
That's just data.
It's fucking childish and 99.9,
it's just fucking hilarious.
Can even explain it.
I think that's why.
Well,
maybe it's because guys are childish.
Why I think guys are so funny is because we have the fucking maturity level.
I don't give a fuck what we're doing in our lives.
How much responsibility we have,
how much money we're making,
how good a husband or a father or anything like that we are.
Um,
we're still immature as hell unless you just a fucking boring Douche.
Anyways.
The fuck do I know?
Huh?
What do I know?
The world doesn't want my sperm.
Why would you listen to me?
Oh,
this just in the world says,
fuck you bill.
Fuck you.
And you'll read nuts.
We don't want them.
Oh my God.
How much of an Egomaniac of my that that doesn't even bug me that I actually
find it funny.
The world just said no to me and I still feel good about myself.
What kind of a man has an ego to that level?
I'll tell you the kind of man who has the balls to do a podcast by himself,
who actually thinks he's fucking interesting for an hour.
Know,
gee,
you know what?
I think I was a little too mean on the fatty.
I did.
I did what everybody does.
I judge fatties the way the world judged my sperm.
You don't see people.
This is why.
This is why my podcast is so mean.
This is why I don't give a shit about other people's feelings.
This is why I say cry me a fucking river.
I don't give a f.
The world just said no to my just the fucking world.
There's people out there,
okay,
they're shitting on the side of the road after they fucking,
you know,
skip out of a bamboo hut.
Okay?
I come up with my,
just,
Eh,
I'm all set.
I'm going to wait for something better.
There's people in fucking Columbia,
Venezuela,
who,
those people that,
uh,
what's his face help helped out.
Escobar.
They were living at the dump.
They were living in a junk yard.
He went out and built him a small city.
Uh,
those people also said no to my ges.
This just in the world says so.
I just don't,
I don't have any fucking,
uh,
I just don't have any sympathy yet.
I do.
I understand.
People don't want to be fat fucks,
you know,
the same way you understand that you'd like the world to welcome your just as
opposed to say no to the world outside zone.
[inaudible]
oh,
I ate a paper.
Yes I did.
I still rode a bicycle.
Just let me paint a picture for you.
Okay.
Big Reddish Orange Afro riding a beach rambler with white wall tires is big
peewee Herman bike with white wall tires.
Fucking insanely giant tires.
Like if you went fast enough and slammed on the brakes,
it sounded like a car.
It went,
people thought it was the shit.
Now they didn't,
nobody liked me.
Right.
So anyways,
I had paper route money people I had been doing the paper I have from third
grade to freshman year in high school.
I got up every fucking morning cause there's no day off with papers.
If you notice that even on Christmas when you wake up,
right?
You walk by your children and that woman that you're married and you got your
robe on,
you know,
tied Nice and tight.
See a fucking Hogan doesn't spell out.
So all a day put your junk away,
dad.
What the fuck?
Right?
And you walk to the front door,
there's the paper.
Why you think it got there?
Well nowadays it's probably,
it's probably thrown there from a car out a car window by a 40 year old.
All right.
But when I was young,
all right,
it was still delivered by children.
Yeah,
it was great.
Back then they had paper boys.
Then the broads had to come along.
Well,
what about paper girls?
Why can't we do that awful job?
You know,
typical fucking broads.
Oh,
this is early.
Am I,
are you going to say that six minutes in?
Let me tell you something about these fucking lady.
You know the funny thing about feminism
is they sat the,
sometimes you just,
you got to really look,
you got to really examine what you're asking for.
It's kind of like gay people pushing for the right to get married.
It's like,
did they have any fucking idea what they're signing up for?
You know,
there's so wrapped up in being treated the exact same way as heterosexuals,
which they should be,
right?
I'm not giving you a rough time,
their twinkle toes.
You should be okay,
but they're rare.
There are some advantages of being gay.
One of them is you don't have to get married.
You get have
a life plot.
Right?
And at no point in the relationship can the dude sit there,
right?
He's got his head on your shoulder,
plane with your chest hair,
you know,
and you can just feel the sadness of his head.
And then you go,
what's a matter of Scott?
You know?
You know,
I don't know why Scott struck me as funny.
What's the matter of Scott?
You don't seem like your normal self.
And he can be like,
oh,
it is.
So where is this relationship going?
And then you're in that,
then you're in that and then you got to get married and he got to put all your
shit on the line,
right?
Well let me ask you this,
gay guys,
what if Scott is a fucking bum?
Uh,
what if he sucks at math?
What if,
what if he's not an earner?
You ever think about that during your parades?
Have you ever thought about that?
What if he's a fucking loser?
Loser?
Huh?
Then what?
And then three years later you're under a lot of stress cause you got to fucking
support his ass too.
You don't have time to go to the gym and keep your abs all in shape,
right?
And all of a sudden you get a little doughy,
little doughy,
right?
He's a,
he's a guy.
He totally judges people by how they look in a tight shirt,
right?
He fucking walks out on you,
walks out on you,
takes half your shit and now you got to pay alimony for a God damn man.
And do you ever think about that?
Well you should.
All right.
Don't fuck into what y y you know?
Oh,
that would be great.
Do you guys have common law marriage
or do they not even recognize that because you both either women or both guys.
I mean,
the fucking advantages of that is just,
it's,
it's incredible.
You know,
it's almost worth the rejection.
Wouldn't you say?
Oh,
whatever.
Go Fuck Yourself.
[inaudible] [inaudible] all our bill,
my younger brother and I have been having this debate about whether he took his
girlfriend's virginity.
All right.
This is going to be about a guy who's still a virgin.
This might get ugly.
All right.
My brother and I have been having this debate about whether he took his
girlfriend's virginity.
Basically my brother who is now 20 has been dating the same chick since they met
in Catholic high school.
He says his girlfriend is saving herself for marriage,
like a good Catholic.
My brother and the other hand lost his virginity before they met,
so get this,
get a load of this guy's writing it like it's the 20 here's the kicker.
I say,
instead of typical fucking this chick,
let's my brother.
Fuck her in the ass.
Let's read that again.
So get this,
get a load of this instead of typical fucking this chick,
let's my brother fuck her in the ass.
And furthermore,
she has convinced him that she is still a virgin.
I tell my brother,
uh,
first consider yourself lucky because most women will never let you do that.
And second,
this chick is not only a fucking whore,
but his fucking royally stupid according to her Catholic standards.
If you only have anal sex,
then you're still a virgin.
This is complete horseshit.
It's sad to me because I know this isn't an isolated incident,
but rather a growing phenomenon.
Uh,
what websites are you going to,
sir?
Um,
it appears that more and more so called Catholic school goody two shoe bitches
have been brainwashed to think that they are holy in the eyes of the Lord by
maintaining their virginity even though they spread their butt cheeks and show
that our writer,
right Jesus Christ,
please bill for the love of,
of all that is holy help me,
could help me to convince not only my brother but all these so called children
of God that even if you don't fuck a girl in their vagina,
that a girl loses her.
Virginia,
virginity,
when she gets banged in the EA problem with lack of sexual education in this
country,
particularly when it comes to like Catholic school and relaxing.
Before you get on your soapbox,
do you feel,
to get on my soapbox,
I just knocked you off.
Do you feel that this woman is still a virgin?
No.
She's not a virgin.
Even though when you go to put it in her,
her hymen isn't broken but her hymen isn't place.
It's basically,
but the seal hasn't been broken on the bottle,
but you screwed in the bottom and all the liquid is poured out
gospel now because it's like you're supposed to be,
there's this virtuous woman.
So yeah,
it does create this weird complex in you.
And then you do one of them old.
This most Skanky just sex act you could possibly do.
Why is that?
Skanky uh,
I it,
it's just sex.
Look,
listen,
listen.
No.
Listen.
Different sex act as a sex act.
They shouldn't be demonized one way or another.
And I take umbrage with this guy calling his gore a whore just because she's
having anal sacs.
Okay.
Are you a whore?
Because you bang girls shut the fuck up.
That's right.
That's wrong.
That's the wrong way to look at it.
No,
he's not a whore.
Not a whore.
Well,
he's calling her a whore just because she's having anal sex.
Why?
Cause she took it in the age.
So do a lot of people.
How does it make them whores?
It's a sex act,
but it's a dirty,
filthy one.
Well,
that's your issue.
And people need to let that go.
As far as him though,
it doesn't matter.
Matter what he does,
he's never going to be a whore.
He's a guy.
Right?
Right.
Listen,
let me,
I'll explain it to you this way.
If you take that patronizing tone with me,
you,
you already used the word umbrage.
Yeah,
because I'm smart.
Don't get all right.
I don't know what I'm bridge.
I take umbrage.
Um,
I take umbrage with the fact that you used umbrage.
It didn't warn me that you're going to do that.
And you see the look in my eyes.
The fuck is that it was this meet the press.
No,
listen to me.
I've heard a lot of girls are doing that these days.
They're having anal sex thinking that it's not regular sex,
but it's all sex people.
So if you're taking in the ass or you're taking it in the video page,
okay,
let's,
let's see.
Okay.
And a drug sense.
Alright.
Making out.
That's like you had a beer getting felt up.
You smoked a joint.
Going to third,
going to second at what base am I on right now?
Third,
going to third is a like you just did some blow and getting fucked.
No wait,
you're all over.
All over the place.
I lost my train of thought though.
Yeah.
If it was like drugs.
Okay.
First base is drinking.
Second basis we'd third base is coke,
maybe shrooms.
It shrooms.
Home is coke,
and then getting banged in.
The Hess is heroin with some math.
That's like,
you're not coming back.
All right,
so she skipped.
That's what she did.
She went from just sort of drinking and smoking some weed and went straight to
meth.
It's beyond needy.
It's beyond.
You ran past home plate.
You went into the Dugout,
you kept going past the showers and you ran right out of the fucking stadium.
Worried about his brother and the girl that he's fucking,
why don't you worry about getting your own piece of tail?
He actually agrees with you.
He agrees with you that there's,
there's a misinformation out here.
Yeah,
but he's directing it towards the girls that are doing it.
Not to the people who come up with these rules to begin with,
which is what I wanted to explore.
His anger is what I want to explain to you on standing up.
I'm walking around,
I'm about ready to drop knowledge.
All right,
here you go.
This is the deal.
This is why I'm interested in judgment and shaming people.
They just never stop.
Um,
this is why,
if a guy does it,
he's not a whore.
If a woman does it,
she is okay.
This is first
of all why it's,
it's not a big deal if a guy engages in that act.
It's basically,
yeah,
it's because we enter,
okay.
You know,
you're,
uh,
you allow somebody to enter your body that's,
that's like so much more than like,
what the fuck we do?
Let's,
why sex is not a big deal to us.
I've told you this analogy before that basically,
well,
basically like this is the deal.
If somebody said,
hey,
I'll give you 1000 bucks to go over to that.
Does it say there's a birthday cake?
Give you 1000 bucks to go over there and just stick your finger in it.
You do it in a second,
right?
Yes.
If somebody said,
I'll give you 1000 bucks to take that cake and shove it up your ass.
All right?
You'd have some questions.
Where is that cake,
Ben?
What do I get out of it?
You didn't negotiate for more fucking money,
so that's the same thing.
That's just what we do.
Sticking our fingers and cakes.
That's that's,
that's how much sex means to us.
I think that's bullshit.
Well,
I don't expect you to understand it.
Right?
You know,
saying that I don't understand.
This isn't about my,
my comprehend.
That's why you guys,
that's why I don't believe that's why you guys think way more about who you're
going to have sex with because you're letting somebody enter your fucking body.
Now I'm just walking around.
I'm poking people now.
It's conditioning.
It's not like reality.
It's,
it's conditioning.
It's you.
You,
you grew up with this idea that you're supposed to not feel a certain way and do
you use the word society?
I swear to God,
we're just brainwashed from day one that what we do is wrong.
There are many guys who have had emotional moments when having sex with
somebody.
They just don't want to talk about you.
I've had an emotional moment.
Yeah,
like what?
Oh my God,
why are you making it sound like I cried or something?
I never did that.
No,
no,
you never did that.
So what?
Why did you just say that?
You're just making shit up.
You went from the,
I'm sure there's guys out there,
there's no research behind that and then you just threw that out there.
Would you like to meet to talk about my research or would that make you
uncomfortable?
Oh,
this is world series of poker.
You just went all in.
Now I got to figure out if you're bluffing or not.
Am I going to call your hand?
Oh,
you're staring right at me.
Ah,
you fucking pain in the hand holding.
I'm folding.
Why do you always do this to me on the podcast?
This is the second time.
Are you on your bullshit?
I thought that's what I was here for.
You ever do that again?
Saying that,
nodding with your eyebrows.
They're calling you on your bull shit.
The fucking ego of females.
You guys are just always patting yourself on the back.
Are you?
Let me tell you something right now.
Yeah.
If you were a fucking dude right now,
I kick you in the chest and what's your fault?
Right off the bed.
But I can't do it cause that's what you deserve right now.
But I can't do it because you're alleging
[inaudible]
I got an overrated overrated.
Okay.
Picking up a fucking magazine that lists 10 great places to go to breakfast and
then believing that no one else read the magazine and there's not going to be
aligned three miles long the next fucking morning when you show up to get your
pancakes.
That's exactly what happened.
We pull up and I see this fucking looks like a goddamn breadline during the
depression and with Nia and a mom and I immediately just go,
hey,
you guys want to go somewhere else?
And then somebody in the car goes,
well,
it's probably going to be a line everywhere,
right?
So we fucking stand in line for 40 minutes.
Got to the point.
I'm crouching down like my back is killing my lower back.
Like I'm so old,
I can't stand for longer than like 20 minutes without my lower back killing me.
So I'm standing there 40 minutes in,
I'm crouching down like a,
ever see Asians when they have a conversation in China,
how they just fucking Nick Dave,
they can crouch down like that and are people in India,
you know,
they crouched down like that.
They'd been doing it their whole lives.
So their hamstrings are all stretched out.
I was down like that.
My big head turning all red.
I'm trying to stand in a little bit of the shade and a,
I don't know,
I'll find that.
I was like,
look,
let's get the fuck outta here.
Right.
So everybody agreed.
We leave and we end up going,
I mean we stood in line for breakfast so long it was now time to get lunch.
So we ended up going down.
We were on Santa Monica and we go down into West Hollywood and there's a place
down there,
hamburger Harry's,
they have great fucking,
uh,
they've got great burgers and it's one of,
but it's also one of the gayest places you'll have a goatee in your life.
I didn't realize how gay it was.
And I went there and the waiter was like really gay or whatever,
but I didn't really think about it,
right?
So I drop off the ladies and I go over and I parked the car,
I get out of the car and I come walking in and I'm starving.
And as I'm walking in,
all of sudden this guy pushes me in the back,
like gave me a nice little shove.
And I turned around and he goes,
do you need a table?
Fucking,
there's fucking gay dude pushed me in the bed.
He pushed me like,
fuck that.
Like not hard enough to make me stumble,
but hard enough to fuck up the gate of my walk.
And immediately,
you know,
felt the feelings you feel when somebody fucking pushes you.
When I turned around like,
what the fuck?
And the guy's just standing there.
She did a table,
I went nose,
I'm just meeting them over there.
And then he kinda had a weird look on his face and he walked away and I sit down
and he's like,
hey,
how's it going?
How's it going?
I go there.
Fucking gay guy just pushed me.
So I tell her the story and I'm off.
I've got what the,
what the fuck is it?
Some gay thing.
You just fucking go around and pushing people and then Nia goes,
he was probably hitting on you.
Right?
So now my ego kicks in.
I'm like,
fuck,
I still am in shape.
So for any of my fucking twinkle toed listeners out there,
is that how you guys hit on each other?
Or was that just like,
Hey Philly,
do you want a table?
Is that what he was doing?
It's fucking annoying.
Whatever it was.
And I felt embarrassed and I felt bad,
like,
like that look on his face when I went,
now I'm sitting over here like,
then he thought that I,
I don't know what,
yeah,
that I was saying,
get out of here.
You're queer.
You know,
cause that's a whole big fucking thing now you gotta be nice to those guys.
What the fuck I'm saying?
So anyways,
so we sit down.
All right.
And immediately the dude comes over,
oh I can,
I take your order,
we fucking order and we're getting our food immediately the way you should when
you go out to eat.
So now,
despite the fact that fucking the,
the waiter pushed me like that dude who pushed Zidane Oh,
Chara after he scored the goal,
that's basically how he pushed me.
And then I turned around and looked at it.
I'm like,
I was going to run him into the boards basically.
Right.
So they fucking bring the food over.
It's delicious,
everything's going great.
And then all of a sudden
this fucking dude gets on the Mike and he can't see him.
He's like,
yeah,
okay,
everybody show thought good 10 minutes,
right?
And I'd say,
yeah,
go,
what's going on?
She goes,
evidently they're going to have a show.
So it's fucking broad daylight out.
I guess they're going to come out and drag and they're going to do a show like
this.
This is how gave this place is that they're going to have a brunch slash
transvestite Lipsync fucking show.
And I got to tell you,
it was absolutely fucking hilarious.
We was sitting there and the guy on the mic,
it's like 1130 in the morning,
and he said,
cunt on the mic.
He goes,
come on,
bitches,
drink up.
We're having a show.
Don't be a bunch of something.
And he goes,
sorry,
I'm sorry,
I'm just feeling a little cunty
there with Nina's mom.
And this guy starts saying cunt,
like every other fucking word in broad daylight.
And as a comedian,
I had to respect that guy.
All right?
I've never said cunt on stage when the sun's out.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I barely say it on stage.
I say it a ton of times here,
cause it's ridiculous,
but I really don't say it that much on a comedy club stage.
And this dude slash half a lane is saying [inaudible] every other word at
brunch.
And uh,
so anyways,
so they come
down like three of them.
The whole sucked,
right?
He had this giant head with this huge fucking,
uh,
I don't know what blonde wig on.
Okay.
And he,
he was like doing jokes that should have been funny,
but weren't at some point he said something about a bloody pussy and was sitting
here eating brunch and he makes a bloody pussy joke.
So just as a comedian,
this,
this should have been hilarious with timing was awful.
He'd say the set up and then he'd mumbled the punchline and he was annoying me.
The next one came out was all right.
The dude looked like Nancy grace.
So that was cracking me up.
And then,
uh,
the next one looked like a soccer mom
if,
if she was in Battlestar Galactica,
you know,
you know when they have those,
uh,
you know,
they get that Woodstock,
Ellen degenerate haircut.
Kinda had that,
but spiked up and that was hilarious.
And then the last one freaked me out.
There's always one that's going to freak you out because it's going to almost
look like a fucking chick.
So it had like acid plants and it's like I'm trying to eat and I gotta I gotta
get Outta here.
So I go up,
I walk out of the restaurant because you know,
it's one of those deals you,
it's like when in Rome you went into their place,
so you got to tolerate.
Then it becomes,
there's that point where you just like,
all right,
this is,
this is too fucking creepy.
I gotta get Outta here.
You know?
So I walk out and I'm standing on the corner out in front of this place that
turned into the gayest place I've ever been in.
And I got to tell you,
I walked down the street all the time in la.
Nobody ever tells me that they saw me.
Nobody's ever seen me,
nothing.
I come walking out of this place right?
And this behind me is this some the transvestite that almost looks like it,
chick with acid plants and his dancing to salt and pepper push it.
I swear to God.
So I'm standing out in front of that place and it's that part of the song was
going,
bullshit donor donor.
And this guy pulls up from the comedy store,
stopped at the red light.
He's like,
hey bill,
how are you doing?
And I'm just like,
hey,
how's it gone?
Done the and the fucking background and my face literally turned red with
embarrassment.
But fortunately,
fortunately the guy owned a restaurant across the way.
So then he ended up coming out,
coming over to me,
coming out.
How fucking funny is that?
He comes over to me and he goes,
uh,
you know,
to shoot the shit,
cause I've been telling him I was going to go to his restaurant and that just,
then fortunately Niya and her mom walked out and I've never been so relieved to
be like,
this is my girlfriend and this mom.
I didn't know that there was going to be a fucking,
it was like a s when I got it.
I got a mid eighties,
I don't know what a mid eighties
okay.
Sitcom,
you know,
with this,
this situation.